hello everybody
uh welcome to today's ncbi webinar i'm
going to be talking about some
enhancements to ncbi blast and primer
blast this is peter cooper
if you have any questions you can write
to me directly there at peter.cooper
nih.gov
and i'm one of the people at the ncbi
service desk and i'm also one of the
people that
supports blast wayne is as well and ron
also works for the service desk so we're
going to talk we're just going to point
out the web blast services
that you probably all know about we're
talking about some new features of
primer blast
where it can use multiple templates and
you can link to the primer blast
service from the assembly database we
have some new description table options
that we'll use today and i want to talk
a little bit about some condensed
databases one of which is available
refseq select database and one of which
is an experiment
and we just want to get some feedback
from you all about that
and i'll have that in a survey at the
end of the webinar
so you're probably familiar with this
this is the ncbi blast home page the top
section is
where you would go to do typical blast
searches against databases
nucleotide blast translating blast
protein blast
then there are a bunch of specialized
services and the one we're going to talk
about today
in this talk is primer blast this is a
primer designer and specificity checker
so it designs primers and then it will
check them against the blast database
essentially to see if they're going to
be
unique to your target sequence
okay so the first thing i'm going to
talk about primer blast first
and then we're going to talk about
what's the changes that we've made the
ordinary blast and then talk about the
databases so we have the option to use
multiple templates
we also have these genome assembly
specific databases
and basically this is just a screenshot
of the
primer blast interface here and you can
see you basically what you do is provide
a template sequence in this case
the new feature is you can provide
multiple templates that are similar to
each other
and then design primers for those
against some background database
and this is actually one that we
demonstrated a few weeks ago when we did
a webinar about
model non-model organisms what i'm doing
in this case is i'm checking i'm
designing primers for a number of
different species for a similar
target the other thing you could do is
to take some splice variants and that's
the one we're going to do today
and design primers that would amplify
all those supply experience
basically your primer results over there
on the lower right show you
you've got all these primers and they
were designed to avoid regions in that
alignment you see at the bottom
where they're a bunch of mismatches so
this is pretty useful tool to make some
primers that'll amplify
a number of different sequences from
different samples or from different
organisms the other thing you can do
with this
is you can set that specificity database
to be
a genome assembly for example if you had
a set of primers that you designed that
could amplify something from
one species you can check them in one of
these partially assembled genomes like
this one
this is for the humpback whale so i
could run
click the run primer blast here i can
also blast the assembly from this
position on the assembly database
um but what this does is it sets that
assembly as the um specificity checking
database
it's going to take this pair of primers
that i'm going to run this is using
primary
blast to check your primers against this
humpback whale genome and i can see that
it does
match although not perfectly to a region
on that assembly and i could
that would be basically that's going to
be this gene which has happens to be the
molecule of the gene that i could then
go in and try to get out of this
partially assembled genome
we'll do an example like that in a few
minutes
on the other thing that you may have
noticed is that there are new options on
the descriptions table that's the top
portion or the really not in
the top portion anymore but it's the
table that shows you your matches
on the blast output so this is your
typical descriptions table and i've
added some of the non-default options
here now that are very helpful so you
can see that you have the ability to
add scientific name and common name for
the organism the tax id
and the accession link those are the
things that are new
so check that out it's very useful if
you want to quickly scan to see what
organisms you have in there which is
what we're going to do
in an example later on you know you
might not recognize the scientific name
but you might recognize the english
common name for that organism
you can also download this table
and comma separated variable format so
that you just load that directly into
excel if you want to
which is pretty helpful the other thing
we're going to talk about today is some
changes that relate to
making what i'm going to call condensed
or concentrated databases
you know originally i wanted to call
these reduced databases because they're
reduced in size but that doesn't quite
capture what we want to talk about
because really they're trying to get
just some
core information out of the database so
the problem that we're having of course
is that the databases are growing at a
tremendously fast rate
and so some of the new sequences that
are added they're not particularly
adding a whole lot of information
so we're going to talk about two sort of
databases that help with that problem
one is called refseq select
and the other one is this clustered
non-redundant database
that i'll talk about in just a moment
see how that works
so refseq select is a project at ncbi it
really has two aspects to it
there are transcripts that are being
produced for mouse and human only
um this is part of a larger effort
called the match annotation from
ncbi humble evi are called main
basically what we're trying to establish
is a single transcript and protein to
represent each
gene so that's going to get rid of all
the different splice variants that you
might have
for a particular gene it's going to make
a much cleaner set of results when you
search blast with it
so that's why it's kind of helpful the
other one
which is kind of a different thing but
it's it's sort of part of the same
project
in the same database that ncbi on the
protein side
is we're making a set of prokaryotic
proteins from
ncbi reference and representative
genomes this is about 13
000 genomes out of nearly a million
prokaryotic genomes that we have at ncbi
and they represent
important taxa or every species that we
have available
if you want to learn more about that
effort you can take a look at the links
that are on this slide here
but they provide some reduced database
sets
so here's what they would look like on
the pull down list
so if you look at refseq select
for the protein database it's about 26
percent the size of or the length really
is what i'm trying to say here because
this is about
the number of sequences pretty much 26
of refseq protein so it's much smaller
and for the rna sequence databases it's
about
0.1 percent the size of refseq rna so
these databases are going to be
you're going to be able to search these
much faster than you could search
the parent database a related idea
would be to cluster sequences at a
certain percent identity and we've
started to do some of that to look at
that as a way
to make your results a little bit easier
to interpret um
so right now we have an experimental
database that's clustered at ninety
percent identity
and overlaps at least ninety percent the
length of the lower longer
sequence that makes a less redundant
database
for example one thing that would often
happen here is it will collapse all the
higher primate sequences
into one sequence for searching but
that's useful if you want to expand your
look back time
to do a blast search that's not too
takes too long it doesn't take too long
it has a small set of results you can
see hey does this protein get conserved
all the way back to the base of the
vertebrates for example
because right now when you do that kind
of a search
you're not going to see past the mammals
for the most part with the number of
sequences that we show you
this database at this clustering level
is about 41
of nr so it's going to be much faster to
run
so what i'd like to do with with all
these things we talked about is to do
some examples
so we're going to design some primers
for the splice variants for
p53 a human gene um
then we're going to check the primers
against the japanese macaque assembly
and i just put a picture of the japanese
package over there um and then we can
take
that macaque assembly we can find the
contact that my primers hit
and then i can use the refseq select to
basically annotate the p53 gene in that
context
and then i'll show you some example an
example with refseq select protein just
to show you the difference between
searching
the mutil protein from e coli against nr
i mean not against it against the refseq
protein versus what that looks like with
refseq select
um there's another example in here that
i don't think we're going to have time
to do but it's in the handout
um that's on the ftp site and you can
also get to it
if you want to iran maybe you can put
this in the chat that
compressed url there that should take
you directly to the text file that has
the
accession numbers and other things you
need to run these blast searches
so that second one the hume the animal
abc transporters we probably won't have
time to do that today but
you're welcome to try that one yourself
and i'll show you in a minute they have
preserved
blast url so you can always load those
uh and the last thing that i definitely
want to show you today is what it looks
like to do a clustered database search
with
human apolipoprotein e so we can find
homologs in other species and we'll take
advantage of that
common name column that you can get a
descriptions table to take a look at our
results
so what i'm going to do now is to switch
over to a web browser
okay so this is the ncbi homepage and
the first thing we're going to do is to
let's go ahead and get
a p53 and we'll take advantage of some
of the little
search shortcuts that we have nowadays
on our website so
if i type in the symbol for our name if
you want to call it that for a human
gene
i do a search with it
i usually get this little device here
that we've
called at ncbi we call this a known item
search obviously you're probably looking
for this
gene and we gave it to you right there
and so you can see that this
gene has 15 transcripts these are
different splice variants of gene
let me just open this panel here to show
you something
so notice that what out of these 15 we
picked one
this one right here to be that refseq
select thing
and we'll come back to refseq select in
a few minutes when we do a search
um using a contact we're going to find
right now what i'm going to do
is i'm just going to get these sequences
so there's 15 of them here
okay and there they all are these are
all different splice variants
of this gene and let me just get
the convenient thing i can do here is to
go ahead and get
an accession list we're going to use
that accession list
in primer blast to design primers for
this whole set
of splice variants i can just go ahead
and select and copy that to my clipboard
and then i can just go get go over to
the primer of last page
i'll just go to blast
and then i can click here to get the
primer blast
and then i'll just paste these in now
before i do that i've got to remember
that i'm not using one template right
i'm using a group of sequences so i'll
just click that tab
paste these in here
so i have the 15 nucleotide accession
numbers in there
and then on primer blast so it's these
are all the primer designing parameters
we won't really change any of those
right now
and then i can look down here and i can
see what my database says so basically
i'm comparing this to the human
refseq rna database i want to make sure
that these primers are going to be
unique to those targets the ones that i
set up there
and then i can just press get primers to
run this
now this takes a little bit longer to
run than i want to wait
while i'm talking to you all because
we'd have a lot of
sitting around time so what i'm going to
do is um
i've saved the job id and i can go ahead
and just
load that result
and you can do this too with your own
jobs
they don't persist forever but they
persist for a day or
so
okay so you can see this is the same
kind of result i showed you
in the slides so here are all the
templates here there are different
splice variants there's places where
there are gaps there's a longer one here
um not any mismatches which is what you
would see if there were different
species
but i want to make sure my primers don't
land in any of those gaps and they did
they didn't they also the other thing
that i can see here that's interesting
is
some of these primers are going to be on
different exons some of them are not so
primer pair
7 actually
which i'm going to zoom in
actually it's completely within a coding
exon that means it could work with a
messenger rna sequence
you know a cdna library or it could work
with genomic dna
and so that's what we're going to use in
a moment to try to find this gene in
that
attack um genome so
what i've done to make slides convenient
is i've taken these uh primers here
and copied them so that i have them in
that file and like i said that file
isn't the link where
uh ronald posted in the chat if you want
to look at it
so what i'm going to do is go back to
primary last
not go back to printerblast i want to go
to
the assembly database first because what
i want to do is to load the assembly
that i want to use
as a database in primerblast so let me
go back here to the
ncbi homepage and i'm going to go to
assembly
i'll just run a search here
so this is an organism search to find
all the primate assemblies
and i'm what i want to do is to find
ones that don't have annotation
because we're going to do our own
annotation here
to be able to spell and type this is a
filter that you can apply to a search
in that database
okay and we're going to pick i'm going
to use this
genome disassembly here this is macaque
which is a japanese macaque this is a
old world monkey my cats are not that
far removed from
the lineage that gives rise to the great
apes and humans so these human primers
that i designed
they probably will work in this assembly
so we can try that out
so i'll just load the assembly record
it's just a whole genome shotgun
assembly contains a whole bunch of
contigs
and i'll go ahead and click the run
primer blast button
or link here that will toss me over into
primer blast and now
i can look down here and see that that's
now the database that i'm going to be
checking the the primers again so i'm
going to put my primers in there
now like i said i've got them over here
in a convenient place
my sequences
there's a forward primer that was
designed by primer blast for the
p53 human transcripts
and then i can go ahead and tell it to
it says get primers but what it's
basically going to do is to see what
those primers match
in this particular database
so this is using primer and blast in a
different way than we used it before
we're not designing primers but we're
checking parameters
against the database and again
i don't want to wait that long for this
to run it takes about a minute or so
so i'm just going to go ahead and
retrieve the
results for us
okay
okay and so there's a nice perfect match
uh for this particular contig right here
so
and there's also a another conjugate
that doesn't match perfectly but we're
going to
figure that this is probably the macaque
p53 gene right here on this contact
right here so i'll go ahead and retrieve
the contig
it's not too large it's 27 000 bases
long
so if i want to now i can sort of let's
try to use that refseq select database
to annotate to find
the equivalent of the human p53 gene in
this
monkey genome so i can just click this
over here i'm going to go ahead and just
grab this sequence because sometimes
when you go to blast it has settings
that you don't want when you change them
you might lose your query sequence we'll
just see what we get when we go over
there
so i just click run blast it throws it
in there and actually it's not bad
that's what i want to do
so this is the cat contag what i'm going
to do down here is change this database
now
to refseq select right and
i don't care what should be in there
should be mouse and human sequences i
don't really care about the mouse one so
much
so i can go ahead and just type human in
this organism box here
we can grab homo sapiens that's going to
limit me to those transcripts
and one thing this is just kind of a
useful thing to be aware of
this is a monkey
genomic dna and monkeys and humans have
interspersed repeats that are related to
each other
and so it makes a big mess if you don't
mask that kind of sequence when you're
using a piece of genomic dna and this is
just a useful thing to remember
if you're searching with a big piece of
vertebrate genomic dna you want to do
species specific repeat filters so i'm
going to check that here
and this is the human filter but that'll
take care of the macaque repeats
to you can there is a macaque filter
there too but
it's the easiest one to find right there
then i'll run this
and again i'm not going to wait around
for this to take place
sometimes it comes back before i manage
to copy and paste my
url will sing
i did okay that's fine
and sure enough actually it turns out we
we got another
gene that looks like it's probably
correct that's that matches
this cdna as well and if you want to see
this
just a good way to look at this
alignment is just this graphic summary
because it gives you a really nice
cartoonish view
here's the p53 gene these are the exons
of the p53 gene
if you want to display that in a more um
interactive way you can just click on
graphics here
that's going to load that content into
the graphical sequence viewer
and you can see the matches here and
there is basically
it's aligned this human cdna
against this unannotated macaque contig
and that's pretty much a good guess of
what the
p53 gene looks like in this organism
okay so let's do a couple of things with
the refseq select protein databases
hopefully we'll do one thing with that
and then i'll show you the
cluster databases and um
then we'll throw it open to some
questions
so one real dramatic way to see what the
clusters database do for you is to work
with
bacterial proteins and so that's the one
i'm going to show you
um so let me take a bacteria
this is e coli which is one of the
bacteria that we have
a tremendous number of assemblies for
and tremendous numbers of proteins for
when i do this kind of a search with
that
uh no item search thing it actually
gives me the one from one of the
reference genomes
and so i can get this refseq protein
here
and i could do the same thing we've been
doing i can run blast with it
and so what i want to do is show you
what happens when i run it against
refseq select
versus what happens when i run it
against the refseq protein
and i won't bother to launch those you
already know how to
do that and we've shown you how to do
that so let me just show you what refseq
protein looks like
and the thing about it that's you know
this is only a hundred
matches so i could ask for more than
that but notice we never
left e coli right so everything in this
result is e coli so if i'm looking for
homologs and other species of bacteria
i can't do it there's just too many e
coli proteins in here
when i do the same thing against refseq
select protein
i can do a little bit better than that
so let me show you what that looks like
if you're trying to find homologs
outside of e coli
and that's the way to go
and so you can see i pick up other intra
bacteria here intro bacteria ac like
citrobacter
and klebsiella and all these other
things here so
this is a much this is a reduced
database or a condensed database but now
i can at least get to see the different
bacterial general which i couldn't see
before
all right so the last thing i want to do
real quick with you is to just take have
you take a look at what happens with the
clustered database
and i've already loaded those results
this is a page that is not we don't want
people using this just yet
basically what i'm going to do is to
take the human apo e protein here
i took the the refseq select version of
it
and i'm going to search against nr i'm
also going to search against this
clustered nr here
and i'm limiting this to john
vertebrates and what i want to show you
is how
much we can increase the look back time
when we do that
so i've got the two results here
and these links are in your handout too
so here we have um the results against
nr
and what i've done is i've activated the
common name so we can see the
the names of the organisms here
and you look and you notice that as we
get down here
we have to go a long ways before we even
get out
of the primates so the first non-primate
sequence
in this output is this one right here
that actually happens to be a bat it
doesn't have a common name
here's a rodent there's a woodchuck
here's another marmot
and you pick up some other primate
things depends on how
complete the sequence is but you really
don't get very far
in fact you don't really get past the
mammals here
you go to the bottom of this the only
the only organisms in this list there's
one exception because there's a
contaminant in here but i won't
bother you with that these are all
mammals
so we never saw anything beyond the
mammals that's not because there's not
homologs it's just
there's just too many mammalian
sequences in there
and you might not be interested in all
these primates maybe you want them to
all collapse and so that's what the
cluster database does for you
so if i do it with against the clustered
nr
i start to see some different things
going on here so quickly i'm
getting down into other kinds of
organisms here
so we can look for things in here for
example if we wanted to find
let's say we want to find some whale
sequences
should have found something oh you know
what that one got collapsed so we won't
do that but let's
go whales on the other one
spelling was helpful so
you can see that we're outside of the
mammals here's some fish this is a
goldfish so i found that by the common
name goldfish
if you want to look for the whale
sequence it's over here which is what i
meant to show you
so we can find the sperm whale over
there we don't find the sperm
whale over here because remember these
sequences are collapsed then we're only
showing you one representative of it
and so there has to be a way for this to
be useful for you to expand these and
find all the sequences
that are part of that collapsed cluster
and if you want to look to see um the
different organisms here i just want to
make a plug for the taxonomy report
it shows it's a good way of seeing what
organisms are in here
and i've gone all the way down to the
taxonomy version we can see we're at the
base of the jawed vertebrates
so i can close up things here if i want
to i've already done some work on this
so you can see
i can expand this to see the the
tetrapods including all the mammals
and then here we have some fishes
even we have some um cartilaginous
bishops here so we got all the way to
the base
of the jaw vertebrates by using that
clustered database
and only 250 descriptions
okay so that's my
demos let me just go back over here to
the slides and
this last slide has some urls for things
that you might find helpful
um notice we have an ncbi insights blog
that
url is on here too so go there if you
want to learn more about a lot of these
features i showed you today because
we've got little articles about them
there
blast news is another way to learn about
releases
that have features like this in them so
let's open it up round it to questions
great we have a number of questions um
let's go ahead and start off
with uh templates um
one of the viewers today was interested
in the primer blast
where you showed that you could run it
against um cell sequences
and he was interested in is it possible
to run
primer blast against several genomic
assemblies all at one time
yes it's possible you can't do it in the
way that i
did it today so there is a way to
um let me go back to my web browser here
let me get a tab open that has primer
blast in it
the way you may need to help me out here
um there's a way to set a custom
database here
i can't remember exactly how you have to
activate that
yeah yeah there yeah there you go so you
could
you could potentially put some accession
numbers down here
um to use more than one um
assembly will not take assembly
accessions unfortunately
so if you had chromosomes from a
particular assembly you could put those
in here
just a warning that it it could quickly
get
too large for this to work um because
the blast portion of a primer blast
search
is sort of a wide open search and so
it's very
expensive to run it consumes a lot of
resources
and so it may just get out of hand real
quickly if you do that but it's possible
to enter accession numbers down here
don't forget you need to change your
organism down here to what
you want to use so
it's possible but it's probably not as
deluxe as you would like it to be and i
you know part of the problem is that the
assembly databases are going to get
quite large if you start adding a lot of
them in there
thanks peter we have a series of
questions about
primer blasts specifically and primers
itself so i'm going to kind of go those
in order and we have a couple of just
application questions one of them let's
start off with
designing primers in general in primer
blast and here's a just a general
question
what parameters should one keep in mind
in order to design a good primer pair
are there things that they should
consider when they're looking at the
primer blast page
well i think the defaults are probably
your best option
and that's why they're set that way um
you can mess around with the so what
you're looking at essentially is sort of
a hybrid
application so this top part here
these are the parameters that a program
called primer3
which is a public domain program or
somehow we can use it we've incorporated
it here
that's what designs the primers and so
you can you can change your tms and all
that stuff and that's all the kind of
stuff that you do for your pcr
um these are optimal ones here
um you can change your product size
again
these are sort of product sizes that
most people work with
you know the bigger your product the
less yield you're going to get in your
pcr
so as a first pass i wouldn't change any
of these things
now you can do some things about you
know how your primer
matches to your sequence and this is
more about like you know if we know for
example we knew where the exon exon
junctions were on that
transcript you could say hey make sure
that these things are on different exons
but they only amplify
mrna and things like that but there's
there are so many parameters here that
you can mess around with and i don't
even
want to show you this but i'm going to
down here too
so it's really a matter of i would say
use the defaults and then if you have to
start tweaking things
you just have to start looking at these
and see what gives you the results you
want to have
obviously in pcr sometimes you're forced
to make primers for sequences that
are not optimal and so in some cases you
just kept the pick primers by eye
but this will give you primers that are
more likely to work
i hope that answers that
great um another question and this is
some more kind of a basic blast question
they are interested in designing pcr
primers and often
a single template gets either selected
or an accession gets put in this pcr
template box
and the question is do they need to
blast
both the sense and anti-sense or
regular sequence and reverse complement
or
can they just get away with only using
one just one
i mean i'm not sure quite i don't quite
understand the question you can only put
one strand in here
right so you put your sequence in here
it designs primers for
it's going to design primers that you
would put in this box eventually
there's going to be the forward primer
and the reverse primer on your
template sequence so
no you just need to put one strand in
here that seems to be the question
yes that's exactly a question okay cool
um one that's a little a little more
uh complicated but it's a great question
um when designing primers for multiple
sequences can you get degenerate primers
a lot of people are interested in
finding degenerate primers or using
degenerate primers to tease things out
is that possible currently with the
system no it's not possible with primer
blast primer blast will not work with
degenerate primers
i can understand how it's useful i
myself have done that in the past
um but there's there isn't a simple way
to do it in primer left
um part of it has to do with the blast
search because blast doesn't work with
degener codon you know in places where
you use one of those bases like ionizing
and things like that so
um no it's not possible right now great
before we go on to more of the direct
applications uh one
person just wrote in recently so if you
have an accession
but you want to just look at a query
range
since you're on this page how would you
identify a query range
well so you can't on this page
you would do that by just putting in the
range that you want
that makes sense now this tells you
where you want your primers to go
on your query but that's a little bit
different than what
what the person is asking i think um so
you're just gonna
you know in other words if you want if
you want you don't want to put a human
chromosome one
in here right you want you obviously
you're going to have some kind of gene
in mind like you want to get the exon of
a particular gene
get that sequence and put it in here but
there isn't the way to indicate the
range
um like you can with glassware the range
of the query sequence you can say where
you want your primers to bind
forward in reverse primers and i do that
all the time so like if you're trying to
amplify an exon you can say hey i want
my primers to be in this
intronic region you know outside of that
exon
but no there's no way to specify the
range of the template
necessarily except by using these boxes
okay one one last question from the same
person
um also if you're wanting to do two
sequence um a sequence search for pcr at
this
at the same time let's say you want to
do two sequences
can they put in more than one accession
and have it run
well they can use the option that we
talked about today to put more than one
sequence in there but they have to be
related very closely related to each
other
so there's no way to run two primer
blast search two independent primer
blast searches at the same time
there's no way to do it in batch except
for this feature here where you
these sequences have to be very similar
to each other for this to work
because it has to find a region it has
to find a region where it can bind a
primer where the sequences are 100
identical
and match the criteria for designing
your primer
great now we have more application
questions one of them
is specifically about using primers what
if they happen to have
a set of primers and they want to be
able to figure out
how where it would amplify is there a
way to
identify what region would be amplified
would they
were they set to primers yes and in fact
we we did that today um we just we found
what region would be amplified from a
piece of
genomic dna but you can just put your
primers in in these two boxes here
forward in reverse and then you have to
figure out like
okay what's my target database right am
i amplifying it from a human cdna
library well then this is correct
if i want to be real general about it i
can go here
and say something like amplify it from
the default nucleotide database
and maybe just say i mean probably you
have some idea what group of organisms
it is let's say it's mammals
you can put that in there and then you
can just see what they amplify
just in exactly the same way with the
demo we did today where we
we showed that they amplified that
region on that on that
primate assembly the macaque assembly
that we did today
so yeah this is one of this is one
typical way to use primer blast
what do my primers amplify the other way
of course is
how can i make progress to amplify this
particular sequence that i'm putting in
the template
box great i have just two last questions
since we're coming up towards the end
and they're both applied questions and
the first
question again is kind of conceptual
let's say you have a sequence you've
amplified
and you want to identify the organism of
that
sequence what should you rely on after
you do a blast search
should it be query coverage percent
identity e-value
what is what would you look for to try
to identify
what that organism is well yeah that's a
good question and it's not
it doesn't have a single answer i don't
think it depends a lot on
the the kind i mean we've done a couple
of webinars about this particular topic
um and so you kind of want to look
i think probably the simplest answer is
you want to look at both
coverage and percent identity those two
things together
e-value i think for identification
is it doesn't really enter into it right
because you know they're just going to
be they should be just
zero your e-values are going to be
extremely low
so it really depends on
you know how big your query sequence is
versus how big the database sequences
you're matching so if you're doing like
a 16s or something like that
you know is the database 16s how big is
it does it cover the whole thing does it
cover part of it
those kinds of considerations
so it requires that you look at both
percent identity
and the query coverage and how they will
how the length of the database sequence
relates to the length of your query
sequence
so there isn't a single thing i don't
think
great now the next question i think
actually
could even go beyond blast there's
something new
the person is interested in finding
orthologs are there any new ways
or improved ways of finding orthologs
well sure this is as you say this is
beyond blast but
let's just show them you saw it in
passing
uh when i showed you this
so there's a button right here so if i
have a human gene and i want to know
what the orthologs are i can just press
this button right here
and so here are the ones that we've
calculated
and you can browse this by group of
organisms
you know suppose you're interested in
fish fish
you know chili fishes i don't know
so there's the orthologin so i printed
on
depending upon the gene you can go
beyond this
so orthologs by our definition are you
know we know it's the same gene
because we know the genomic context the
genes around it
you know but then if you're going you
know far away
looking at things that are very
distantly related you can also get this
gene
similar to tp-53 and that's going to
take you outside
of these um the vertebrates here which
is what we've done
at this point to the orthologs so you
can see
things in other organisms taking a
chance clicking on the link
let's see if this is going to work yeah
so
we got all these other kinds of animals
in here
so we can see we've got hits the
arthropods platform segmented worms
mollusks
nematodes in addition to the ones that
we saw before
where we had chorate sequences river
sequences anyway and also we have some
jellyfish sequences here or at least
nigeria of some kind
um another jellyfish hydrozoons and
anthony's corals
so that is the thing that we have now
available for
getting orthologs or related sequences
that's outside of blast
thank you um we're going to round
everything
up with a couple of answers to some
additional questions that
people have had um and this is just
general information
where can we get details of future
webinars and register for them
we have um an ncbi insights blog and
also several different
social media sites twitter uh facebook
um and linkedin is an example and i've
put a link in the chat pod for you
so that you can keep an eye and even
sign up to let us you know
to get information on upcoming webinars
uh that we're releasing finally the last
two questions that people have asked
quite a number of people have asked
about certificates and the answer is yes
you will get a follow-up email after
this webinar and it will have a
certificate
that you participated in this webinar
so we thank you very much for your
participation and the questions
and we hope you have a very good day
thank you rona thanks everybody for
coming
talk to you next time